good morning Hank it's Tuesday so this
is Tetris a video game developed by
Alexey Pajitnov that arrived in the
United States in 1989 for the Gameboy in
the Nintendo Entertainment System aka
the Ness tetris became a phenomenon in
fact it is still the best-selling video
game of all time and lately I've been
wondering why are humans suddenly
getting much better at Tetris first a
little background there are two like
great white whales of nest Tetris the
first is a maxout score if you get
999,999 points the game stops being able
to count your score the second is level
30 so in Ness Tetris the blocks fall
faster as you level up and once you get
to level 29 they drop so fast that it's
almost impossible to move them left or
right making level 30 seemingly
impossible back then there was only one
player Thor Okerlund who claimed to have
achieved a maxout score in level 30 and
lots of people thought he was lying
which as it turns out he wasn't we now
know that Thor was just like much better
at Tetris than all other humans anyway
the weird thing about nest Tetris in
2008 is that far fewer people were
playing it than played back in 1990 and
you would think a larger player base
would mean higher top scores like in
1990 hundreds of millions of people were
trying to solve the problem of getting
to level 30 by 2008 very few people even
still had a Nintendo Entertainment
System let alone regularly played Tetris
on one but a few people never stopped
playing nest Tetris and as tends to
happen when you do something for 20
years they got pretty good at it
also by 2008 the world's Tetris players
were much better connected to each other
than they had been back in 1990 partly
because the internet has connected all
of us and partly because smaller
communities can be more tightly knit
like when a hundred million people are
talking it's hard to hear anything but
noise so Tetris players started to learn
more from each other together they
figured out that you should always build
your well of empty space on the right
side of the screen except as you
approach level 29 when you should build
it in the middle also some of them
developed a new strategy for moving
pieces called hyper tapping and then in
2010 a tournament started the classic
Tetris World Championships which brought
the best players together in real life
and motivated them to improve by a
competition the quality of play at the
tournament has improved every year like
this year several people achieved max
out scores in qualifying and eventual
champion Joseph
became the first person ever to reach
level 30 in front of a live audience
and then there's live streaming tuchis
players around the world now share their
games on twitch and YouTube which allows
other Tetris players to learn from them
even people who've been top level Tetris
players for decades are changing their
play style to reflect new discoveries
and strategy and as a result dozens of
people have now maxed out and Joseph
recently made it to level 31 a land
previously only visited by the legendary
Thor now I want to be clear that getting
a maxout in Tetris is still like
ridiculously hard but it's possible so
why is humanity suddenly getting better
at Tetris because a group of enthusiasts
built spaces both online and off that
allowed people to connect with each
other over what is usually a very
solitary hobby and because small groups
of deeply passionate people can often be
more productive than large groups of
casually interested people I've been
thinking a lot about that which is one
of the reasons rosianna and I ended up
starting the life's library book club
which thanks to your overwhelming
response is now open for enrollment link
in the doobly-doo below but more
generally I know it's fashionable these
days to say that the Internet is a
festering cesspool of toxicity and you
know it is but the Internet is also many
other things including one of the
primary drivers of humanity's improved
performance at a 29 year old video game
really there is no the internet
especially in the era of personalized
feeds there is only for each of us our
internet I don't labor under the
delusion that I can make the internet
better but I do want to make my internet
better and on that front I think Tetris
has a lot to teach me Hank I'll see you
on Friday
PS next week pizza this is coming you
know what that means